und das kostet im durchschnitt weniger
als zehn euro im monat und ich hab das
jetzt auch gemacht und bin haben u2 in
einem unserer letzten videos haben wir
werbung für die klima abgemacht die
klima app erlaubt es die in ein co2
fußabdruck zu berechnen und dann geld zu
spenden um dann zu 25 prozent
neutralisieren zukauf setzen vorneweg
wir prüfen jeden sponsor den wir bei uns
in den videos haben deswegen stehe ich
auch weiterhin zu diesem sponsor aber es
gab einige spannende kritik über die wir
auch noch gar nicht nachgedacht hatten
und deswegen haben wir einige
diskussionen geführt die wir jetzt zu
diesem video hier verarbeiten wollen
denn ich habe jonas unseren redakteur
seit knapp zwei jahren damit beauftragt
so kritisch wie möglich mal hinter die
kulissen von der klima app zu gucken
kann man mit of setting das klima retten
ist das ganze wirklich so günstig und
was passiert wenn ich alle das machen
genau das wollen wir heute herausfinden
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen heute mal zu einem
etwas anderen video das ist jetzt nicht
getrübt sind nicht die tele prompt
sondern wir sind beide hier einfach zum
quatschen zum erzählen ich habe dich
beauftragt damit einmal zu schauen
welche löcher kannst du bohren was
kannst du an diesen sachen über die
klima heraus finden wo kannst du etwas
finden was irgendwie nicht ganz stimmig
ist das muss man natürlich rein
journalistisch sagen ist das auch nicht
hundertprozentig sauber du arbeitest
immer noch für diese firma hier du
profitierst irgendwo auch davon wenn die
teams möglichst gut wegkommt aber dann
direkte auftrag war seien negativ sei
kritisch und genau das hat er auch
gemacht genau ja und das hat eigentlich
auch ziemlich spaß gemacht es war
irgendwie so ganz cool sich eine rolle
rein versetzen zu können und einmal sah
ich bin jetzt so gemein wie möglich und
versuche herauszufinden was nicht stimmt
ja auf der präsentiert und du hast auch
mit dem geschäftsführer der klima
abgesprochen denn das ist ein deutsches
unternehmen die sitzen in berlin und der
geschäftsführer hat uns angeboten einmal
alle fragen die du hast zu beantworten
ja genau dann habe ich mich mit ihm
getroffen das war das mein video call
musste ich mich auch ein bisschen
überwinden so wirklich so gemeint wie
möglich zu sein und wirklich alles ihm
quasi falsch auszuleben zu sagen aber
hier und da hat ein bisschen überwindung
gekostet hat aber mega spaß gemacht und
ich glaube er hat er war auch er fand
dass auch cool und war bereit für die
fragen es hat spaß gemacht dann beginnen
wir direkt damit was passiert wenn man
die app installiert und das erste mal
öffnet denn man wird mit fragen
konfrontiert man soll den co2 fußabdruck
von einem berechnen und kritik von euch
war das sind ja nur zehn fragen des
wirkt ein bisschen wenig und deswegen
frage an dich ist das ganze trotzdem
akkurat also wenn man die frage stellen
würde was ist der bessere test ist
natürlich ein ausführlicher test besser
aber jeder test gibt ja auch meine
schätzung mit einem kompletten haargenau
auf die kommastelle genau der co2
fußabdruck zu berechnen ist praktisch
unmöglich das ist immer ein schätzwert
und ich hab das dann verglichen mit den
tests waren zb wwf oder greenpeace
du kommst also bei mir waren es zwei bis
drei prozent unterschiede also ich komme
ungefähr denselben wert raus ich denke
mal das liegt daran dass halt die klima
von deutschen durchschnitt ausgeht also
11,6 tonnen co2 mit jeder frage
individualisiert ich mich dann quasi vom
durchschnitt weg es ist in ordnung
leider habe ich da nichts gefunden für
das was es sein möchte ist es schon in
ordnung also möchte ich meinen einstieg
geben der ist leuten leichter macht
reinzukommen und davon profitiert das
projekt möchte und man muss dazu sagen
die app arbeitet gerade daran auch noch
mehr fragen wenn man möchte einzubauen
so dass man quasi noch genauer eingehen
kann also es kommt wohl noch dass man
dann eher mit wwf und greenpeace
vergleichbar ist und am ende des tages
ja ist es wirklich nicht so unglaublich
wichtig viel wichtiger ist ja dass man
wirklich in die app reinkommt obmann 1 2
prozent mehr oder weniger hat aber
hauptsache man beginnt dann auch
wirklich mit dem oft eng denn wenn
jemand ihn gelangweilt wird wird nicht
geäußert und das wahrscheinlich das
schlechteste ausgang von allen
[Musik]
komme ich vielleicht größten frage dich
in den kommentaren gesehen hat und auch
dass das mich am allermeisten überrascht
hat ich bin jetzt karl blutspuren laut
der app und ich zahle dafür 11 eur 56 im
monat das ist quasi das was ein netflix
abo kostet und wenn das jeder machen
würde wäre ja die logik hätten wir keine
klimakrise mehr also der grund warum
millionen von arten aussterben warum wir
im jahr 2050 riesigen probleme haben
werden warum es unglaublich viele
flüchtlinge geben wird et cetera et
cetera wenn jeder nur zwölf euro im
monat zahlen würde dann hätten wir das
ganze ding gelöst das kann ja eigentlich
sein kann das wirklich so günstig sein
also ja das ist die kurze antwort ist
kein unrealistischer wert aber dazu muss
man wissen so beim beim ausgleich wie
viel du im endeffekt für die
ausgeglichene oder sogar zurückgeholte
tonne co2 es kommt darauf an wie das
ganze gemacht wird also natürlich ist so
ein kabel capture verfahren es gibt ja
teilweise diese staubsauger die das
wirklich aus der atmosphäre zurück das
ist natürlich viel zu baum zu pflanzen
also das projekt bestimmt maßgeblich wie
viel du im endeffekt zahlst und da muss
ich sagen das war auch einen kritikpunkt
den ich auf jeden fall anmerken möchte
die klima hat sich für sagen wir mal
sehr kosteneffiziente projekte
entschieden also es ist im vergleich zur
konkurrenz es gibt zum beispiel ein
non-profit-unternehmen was was ähnliche
ausgleichsmöglichkeiten anbietet wie die
klima hab da bist du bei mehr als das
doppelte an geld für eine tonne co2 aber
dazu muss man sagen das heißt nicht dass
sie geschummelt wird und dass
irgendwelche kompromisse eingegangen
eine tonne ist eine tonne und die
organisationen die die klima unterstützt
sind mit dem gold standard ausgezeichnet
und auch mit dem verified carbon
standard das sind zwei unabhängige non
profit animation die im endeffekt so
entscheiden ob bestimmte verfahren
schwachsinn oder nicht und die sagen
auch bei den ganzen projektes kassel
also ich habe jetzt schon 3,6 tonnen co2
kostet nämlich tatsächlich seit wir das
video gedreht haben über die klima app
und ich habe seitdem zwölf bäume
gepflanzt ich habe 1345 kilowattstunden
solarstrom produziert und ich habe die
313 nils geguckt wie also ich habe
unterstützt das essen gekocht wird in
dritte welt ländern nämlich mit
nachhaltigen kochstellen genau weil das
problem ist dass sehr viele teile der
welt noch über offenem feuer kochen
unterstützt hat den mega 42 aus deswegen
möchte man dort möglichkeiten liefern
mit zb einem elektroherd zu kochen was
halt einfach nachhaltiges ich habe dann
versucht ein loch zu bohren bei den
bäumen weil es gibt eine sehr bekannte
airline die ich nicht nennen möchte
gesagt hat jeden flug den wir machen
gleichen wie raus und mit uns kannst du
im billigflieger alle machen völlig in
ordnung das problem ist nur wenn ich
jetzt fliege und dafür wird dann nächste
woche einen baum gepflanzt dann sind so
die positiven ausgleich konsequenzen von
diesem baum wie weit liegen die zukunft
und zehn fünfzehn jahren bis dieser baum
anfängt einen positiven effekt zu haben
auf das klima und das habe ich halt auch
der der klima ist ein bisschen ein kopf
geworfen weil ich jetzt geklappt die
machen das tatsächlich so wenn du jetzt
das kaufst wurde der baum gepflanzt der
ist schon groß quasi also der hat schon
co2 eingespart du hast jetzt quasi das
unternehmen das damit quasi ihren
vorkasse gegangen ist auch sozial hast
du das geld dafür gegeben also ich hab
das ein bisschen gewissens kredit
genannt also wenn du jetzt pflanzt dann
ist die ja und dann in 15 jahren ist das
schon in ordnung dass ich jetzt so viel
geflogen bin so ist es nicht tatsächlich
stehen die bäume schon sagst einfach nur
dafür dass dann irgendwann neue wieder
gepflanzt werden können mit deinen baum
steht
wenn wir jetzt alle sieben milliarden
menschen mit diesem video hier davon
überzeugen würden die klima herunter zu
laden den trecker zu machen und dann das
geld zu spenden
was würde dann passieren können wir dann
die klimakrise damit lösen kann of
setting die klimakrise lösen also dass
das hängt natürlich davon hat erstmal
wie skalierbar sind die projekte die
klima unterstützt das hab ich auch den
markus gefragt und er meinte so also
theoretisch ist das erstmal
unerschöpflich was man da machen kann
also es geht ja vor allem auch um die
pflanzen zu gern platz ja klar es gibt
auch diese rechnung die sagen hey wenn
wir jetzt so und so viele bäume pflanzen
dann würden wir wahrscheinlich bei null
rauskommen weil rein mathematisch ist es
ja so wenn ich 50 gigatonnen ausstoße
als menschheit und im gleichen schritt
im gleichen jahr 50 gigatonnen einspare
dann bin ich bei null das ist natürlich
eine ziemliche milchmädchenrechnung weil
wir fangen ja nicht erst ab dem jahr
2000 irgendwann wenn sich alle
entscheiden die klima herunter zu laden
an auszustoßen wir stoßen aus sehr
vielen jahren und sind quasi schon im
minus das heißt bei null rauszukommen
bringt uns jetzt erstmal gar nicht so
viel
weil wir müssen ja noch aufkommt für all
die emissionen die es in den jahren
davor gab und deswegen müssen wir
ultimativen quelle emissionen reduzieren
also gar nicht erst
ausstoßen das bringt ja nichts erst mal
unfassbar viele dinos zu verbrennen und
für die danach wieder reinzuholen also
ja wenn jeder die klimaeffekte jeder
jeder mensch auf der welt hat die
und wir sind bei der 0 erstmal super
unrealistisches natürlich das wird
natürlich nie eintreten aber kein
mathematisch ist das so so viel stress
so viel wird reduziert ich komme ja nur
aus 0 bringt uns nicht viel wir haben
emissionen aus der vergangenheit die wir
einholen müssen die wir zurückholen
müssen und deswegen müssen wir parallel
zum einsparen kommission reduzieren das
ist der weg und das ist das wichtigste
jetzt kann ich aber in meiner modernen
welt in der ich gerade lebe nicht
komplett darauf verzichten ich würde
ganz gerne kleidung jetzt gerade
anziehen ich muss manchmal mit dem auto
irgendwo hinfahren zum beispiel für dreh
ist für diesen youtube kanal ich stoße
co2 aus anscheinend 13 87 tonnen im jahr
würdest du es mir empfehlen mir also die
app herunterzuladen damit ich ein gutes
gewissen habe oder ist das als
ablasshandel ja das versteht dass das
konzept des ablasshandels ein bisschen
falsch also der ablasshandel kommt aus
der kirche dass ich damals wenn ich
gesündigt habe konnte ich halt so
jemanden von der kirche gehen sagt hey
hier geld dafür und dann war weit von
seinen sünden befreit super
kannst de facto ist es aber so dass
ein klima ausgleich im gegensatz zum
abschluss haben wir eine reelle
auswirkungen auf deine außenwelt hat die
wir messen können die wir gemessen haben
einen baum zu pflanzen oder antwort ja
schon gepflanzt wurde spart nachweislich
oder we captured nachweislich co2 das
ist nichts mit was man zu mir vorstellen
müssen das passiert jetzt gerade das
kann man jetzt gerade gemessen
ich glaube aber dass das ablasshandel
argument der darauf abzielt dass dieser
mann plötzlich einsetzt von wegen ich
habe jetzt bezahlt dann ist ja schon in
ordnung und auch das scheint falsch zu
sein das sagt zumindest eine studie der
uni kassel und in köln tatsächlich war
das eindeutige ergebnis dass das
gegenteil der fall ist also man nimmt
nicht den ausgleich als rechtfertigung
dafür jetzt zehn kilo steaks zu essen
sondern tatsächlich verändert sich das
eigene verhalten und man wird
nachhaltiger
[Musik]
klima ist ja eine gmbh am ende des tages
richtig unterstützen mit dem geld auch
ein profitorientiertes unternehmen genau
dass das ist so also es ist ganz
spannend wenn man sich anschaut was mit
dem geld passiert
du steckst 100% geld in deinem monate
rein wenn man bei mir 11 eur 56 genau 70
prozent davon gehen in die 3 ausgleich
programme die duh genannt hast also
solaranlagen bäume pflanzen und neue
flächen in entwicklungsländern weitere
20 prozent gehen daran die reichweite
der kinder zu also dass im endeffekt
genau sowas hier davon wird übrigens
dann werden wir jetzt bezahlt also wenn
ihr das jetzt installiert werden wir von
diesen 20 prozent bezahlen genau oder
auch das letzte video was wir gemacht
haben im endeffekt geht es darum mehr
leute zu erreichen mehr leute laden sich
runter und genau zehn prozent und damit
sind wir beim gmbh teil gehen in die
firma das sind dann natürlich auch
serverkosten gehältern bürokosten was
auch immer aber umsonst also das ist
geld was klima die betreiber der klima
hat als for profit unternehmen verdient
das heißt wenn der ceo markus möchte
kann er sich auch geld außerdem
rausholen und ich unterstütze das
unternehmen das start-up in berlin jeden
monat mit elf mit 1 euro 15 ja meines
geldes und das geht nicht direkt irgend
irgendwie bäume oder was auch immer aber
jemand muss sich natürlich auch
ausgedacht haben jemand muss er
programmiert haben designt haben und an
und für sich möchte man natürlich auch
dass das land dafür künftigen gehälter
bezahlt ob wir sind ein kleines startup
und wollen natürlich auch künftig die
gehälter zahlen aber okay die kritik
verstehe ich auf jeden fall und ein
gewinnorientiertes unternehmen
will eigentlich auch immer gewinnen
machen wieso hat man das ganze nicht
irgendwas stiftungen macht ja richtig
vor allem viele alternativen zur klima
apps sind non profit und wenn sie sich
was abzwacken an es gibt alternativen
die sind vor profit aber und zwar ein
bisschen was aber die investieren dann
geld was sie gewinnen auch in den aufbau
von anderen projekt niemals nicht
finanziell im aufbau dieser projekte
beteiligt sondern sie schicken geld
dahin zu diesem vertrauenswürdige
projekten aber sie bauen die jetzt nicht
aus und wenn man jetzt ganz gemein sein
will und das war ich kurz bei einem
gespräch mit dem mit dem markus dann
könnte man natürlich auch sagen so hey
ihr verdient geld damit dass ich
umweltschädlich lebe und die umwelt
sicher ich lebe desto mehr geld
verdienen die also wahr was sollte nach
strengen kapitalistischen maxime was ist
eure was ist euer ansporn wir zu sagen
dass ich mich so verhalten soll dass ihr
weniger geld vernichten
er hat zu recht darauf geantwortet dass
die app ja schon sehr vielen von
material bereitstellt und das stimmt man
wird
wiederkehrend in der app daran erinnert
ultimativ geht es darum weniger zu
konsumieren und nicht einfach nur eine
rechtfertigung für sich zu finden so zu
leben wie man lebt ja diese erinnerung
kommt immer wieder in der app und das
muss man ihnen schon zugutehalten dazu
kommt das hat langfristig weg wollen
einen ausgleich zu liefern sondern soll
er dahin gehen dass du quasi beraten
wird nachhaltiger zu leben
[Musik]
nun hast du hast die letzten wochen sich
intensiv mit der klima app
auseinandergesetzt du hast paper gelesen
hat mit dem geschäftsführer gesprochen
jetzt würde mich interessieren würdest
du die klima empfehlen ja oder nein und
vor allem würdest du dir sie selber
installieren also ich kann eigentlich
sehr pessimistischen sicht rein also ich
war so hey so lange big playern
wirtschaft die politik nichts machen
kann ich machen was ich will das ändert
nichts und war auch ehrlich gesagt dann
immer ein bisschen angegriffen wenn mir
das gefühl gegeben wo das liegt jetzt in
meiner verantwortung was zu retten oder
irgendwas zu machen während es leute
gibt die zweifellos mehr tun können aber
es nicht machen oder nicht können und
ich muss sagen da habe ich einiges
gelernt jetzt nicht nur durch das
interview sondern weil ich mich mega
vier studien durchgelesen habe im
endeffekt von so einem klima nihilismus
aller das bringt eh nix mehr profitieren
halt vor allem unternehmen weil so wird
für uns der klimawandel so etwas
unausweichlich und dann ist es ja jetzt
auch egal und deswegen hat sich meine
meinung zu of setting auf jeden fall
geändert und ich wäre jetzt nach dieser
recherche auf jeden fall sehr viel
breiter front hat zu laden weil ich fand
das ganz schöne markus hat das mit dem
boot verglichen der meinte so wenn du
einem boot bist und haßloch und das boot
läuft voll mit wasser und niemand
kümmert sich darum gerade das loch zu
stopfen
dann wäre ja meine meinung mit der ich
an dieses video reingegangen bin so ey
hier ist zwar ein eimer mit dem ich
wasser abschöpfen könnte dann mache ich
nicht weil keiner fliegt ins loch also
weist darauf hin ausgerichtet nur weil
das loch grad noch nicht gepflegt wird
heißt es ja nicht dass ich nicht schon
mal anfangen könnte ein kleines bisschen
wasser mit sophie einmal nur zu werfen
und das ist of setting im endeffekt also
das große problem wirst du damit nicht
lösen du wirst nicht die umwelt retten
wenn du etwa monats zahlst aber du
kannst anfangen schon mal dadurch ein
bisschen nachhaltiger zu leben im
endeffekt emissionen vermeiden und ja
also die prima funktioniert und was ich
gefunden habe war jetzt auch alles da
wird man jetzt nicht verarscht oder so
lediglich die tatsache dass es rein
profitorientiert ist stört mich muss
aber nicht jeden stern ja okay dann
vielen lieben dank für deine recherchen
wir packen mehrere links und in die
video beschreibungen volle transparenz
der erste link führt euch zu klima und
es ist ein tracking link der dann uns
davon damit unterstützt sie unterstützt
damit uns um diesen kanal hier aber wir
packen auch andere links noch einen zu
anderen of setting möglichkeiten die non
profit sind die du persönlich
unterstützen würde jetzt würde mich sehr
interessieren ob ihr noch fragen zur
klima im speziellen und zu of setting im
allgemeinen haben schreibt die gerne
unten in die kommentare und jonas und
ich werden unser bestes geben die alle
zu beantworten gerade jonas ist er jetzt
der experte und das hier ist eine art
neues format das wir gerade ausprobieren
wir machen dass er normalerweise nicht
so so und scripted und einfach im
gespräch aber du hast einfach sehr viel
recherche reingesteckt und wir fanden
das war das natürlichste dieses thema
hier zu machen vor allem hat auch mit
ihrer befangenheit weil ich bin ja
eigentlich natürlich dafür das klima
toll ist und dass wir unsere möglichkeit
jetzt hier ein bisschen journalistische
unabhängigkeit zu schaffen schreibt uns
gerne mal in die kommentare ob ihr das
gut fand es langweilig findet ob ihr
feedback hat und ansonsten wie immer
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig war cedric